hey what's up folks Daniel dwire here at
the PlayStation experience Justin hayal
we just sat through about 2 hours of
announcements lots of really fun
announcements lots of fun trailers lots
of reveals as well but really the big
one came right out the gate oh yeah I
mean it felt like E3 just in the number
of of exclusives and exciting things but
starting off with Uncharted that that's
starting really strong and God that game
looks really good exactly unshaded 4
thieves and the first time we've seen it
running it was running I I wasn't sure
if they were playing it on stage clearly
they were because at one stage the dude
just fell through the level uh but we
got to see it being uh played for the
first time live and it was interesting
because uh tonally in terms or in terms
of pacing in terms of like your ability
to get away from encounters not
necessarily mow down dozens and dozens
of people that's something we''re kind
of seen for the first time in the
Uncharted series that's one of the most
important things to me in a new
Uncharted game is that they borrow those
ideas from The Last of Us where it's not
just here's a room full of enemies kill
them all before you can go on like being
able to to evade guys being able to to
take down people silently and crawl
through and maybe not fight anybody at
all and and they introduced that as well
as some really cool new mechanics like
there was one with a whip yes the whip
was great because it looked like he had
jumped off the rock accidentally and
then the whip sort of brought him back
in and what was interesting was when he
did that grapple he also landed on top
of uh the enemy as well like there was
lots of really fluid transitions between
uh cover to Gunplay to melee attacks as
well there was the sort of hiding in the
grass stuff and then what I find really
interesting was at one stage when he
took down uh uh that enemy the other guy
came back around realized that he wasn't
there and then went looking for him but
there wasn't the sort of flare we're
used to in a lot of nextg games where
they're being really obvious about
showing you like where the ghost was
where you were last scene what your
alert status was it was really fluid the
whole thing no it felt like Last of Us
in that sense where it's realistic where
the enemies are going to treat you like
you're a real person and and they're
trying to make the combat even more
exciting like it it is really cool to be
able to run and Gun this time like shoot
guys in the face run up just push them
like that all felt so fluid just the way
that that it melted in with the the
stage like throwing the guy off the
stage just because you you bum rushed
into them like they really got all of
that together and that's all we have
right here at the moment at the
PlayStation experience but stay tuned to
gamespot.com we've got more news
trailers interviews and much much more
stick
around